it's my favorite
we own the airport and that guy sorry
[Music]
Friday morning Chicago to the W gorgeous
outside three hardcore meetings a schlep
from Chicago to the Milwaukee Airport
for a quick meeting and probably not a
whole lot of filming for you Bab and so
I'm gonna have to come up with some sort
of huge rant vlog some days are just
boring for you because they're exciting
for me because I get to be CEO of the
[ __ ] marketing company of the
future and present they just don't know
yet
[Music]
Sneaky's just telling crazy on eBay
stuff like going into meeting number one
big fortune 100 company in Chicago
Batman can't come
Ryan can come like why are you stealing
my clothes
[Music]
dark horse big one
[Music]
[Music]
Babbitt's pumped with you because he
finally now he has he has an episode is
it episode we're back live with Gary
Vaynerchuk Tyler babban Marcus Canty
Chris astok and Gary Vee was your idol
in the entrepreneurship are nobody
nobody nobody but I will say this yeah
well because I never spent time digging
into anybody I always really stayed in a
small you know but I was 34 years old
when I kind of came out to the regular
world because I was in the liquor
business in a family business in New
Jersey met no one knew have we talked
about this all the time I lived in this
weird cocoon so I never did that and I
wasn't a good student or a reader I had
no network I don't even know I didn't I
was so grossly under educated that I
didn't even know to idolize anybody I
analyzed my parents I I'm I'm a ninth I
always tell everybody I'm a nineteen
fifties immigrant much more that you
know what I mean we lived very weird so
nobody that being said I will say this I
really do admire Richard Branson and I
don't know a lot about him so I'm gonna
hedge it a little bit but intuitively
the path of building actual businesses
while actually building a persona as
well and with some some you know kind of
like the the way that he made those two
work work I think is something that I'm
up to and so I I gravitate towards that
all right all electric chair I'll kill
you one deal to go
a White Castle burgers my favorite
we own the air pods and that guy sorry
[Laughter]
right so good job babban way to go on
the setup so here we are in the empty
Milwaukee Airport and gonna be home for
hours later because the big potential
client had a change of plans and I was
like let's get together in January and
sometimes you have to hack because no
time like the present right meaning in
January and the corporate biggest this
world means maybe we'll do something in
the summer may will do something in 2019
meeting in October excuse me November
means you could do something in 2018 so
when that feedback came back I said [ __ ]
it let's take a three hour to two hours
actually and it being an hour and a half
but a two hour drive and we'll come to
Milwaukee and we'll have a meeting in
the Starbucks and and then we'll go on
our merry way so I get back to New York
four hours later which is not a
preference on a Friday night but reality
is is the opportunity to strike was
there and these are the decisions
between work-life balance right like you
know I'm weighing [ __ ] do I want to get
home a couple hours earlier on a Friday
night and so I thought about well the
kids are actually gonna be in bed one
way or the other so I lose out in that
variable and Lizzie and I are grown up
so could stay up later and the Jets have
a bye week this Sunday so I'm gonna be
more all-in on and so you know those are
some of the stuff in the brig that's how
I made the decision of like let's cuz
the schlepping in the hardcore like like
sleep you know off the air but like that
stuff's easy like I'll grind I'm dirt
I'm dirt I'll do anything any time
always humility to the [ __ ] max I'm
[ __ ] absurd Lee a passionate and
romantic about three-hour drives and
like [ __ ] like 2-minute meetings and
the [ __ ] gutter outs you know I'll
meet you in the forest if I think it's
ROI positive so I don't need to be fancy
you know I just need to get it done in
my work life environment but that's why
we're in Milwaukee pickup Brewers we're
all the fingers in the [ __ ] house I
actually love this mess I mean not some
two-bit no no no where's my head guys I
never forgot I don't know what just
happened I almost want to look back at
the film cuz I have such a system by the
way fun fact cuz it's becoming an
interesting episode the system is if you
can give to place where you always pat
your pants
I always pat my pants and I make sure I
have everything I don't know what I
patted I guess maybe the mic I did
something that made me think I don't
know what the hell just happened anyway
[Music]
I'm a little opening here so long I'm
about to go live save your notifications
oh if you're wondering we haven't
transformed it to airport Gary yet
because we have to have the meeting good
afternoon good afternoon good afternoon
Instagram good to see you Ryan Harwood
is here CEO of pure wow what you got the
same person online
no no you shouldn't have now people are
gonna show up in video time for your
favorite superhero
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good focus Oh actually Thanksgiving
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]